either reject nation my name is Greg
Alba my name is John Humphrey we're
gonna do a topper warranty request which
is another video podcast and that today
comes from a man named Eric Horseman
Eric Horseman his request is how has
social media our opinion how has that
affected Fame plus the industry not at
all not at all I think everything is
going great for every famous person out
there producers actors directors it's
all going splendidly for them Hollywood
celebrities are getting away with just
as much debauchery and crime as they
were back in the golden days and that's
the way it should be and social media
isn't ever going to help that out ever
ever end of podcast you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation um
I think it has drastically affected the
industry I don't know I'm not gonna talk
about the big things right now
you know the me2 movement and you know
cancel them I feel like we've dredged
that territory a couple times now I I
kind of when I hear this question I
actually think about all my friends we
live in LA and I think about all my
friends who have greatly been affected
by the rise of social media and how
important that plays into their even
audition process and this goes for
musicians as well this goes for all
kinds of I think even more from than
actors the actresses actually who really
suffer that they don't really get taken
into account what their audition talent
is they get taken into account a lot of
the time more so is that their their
social media following I've met so many
people who have gone to tap there's
several stages when you audition you
know your audition then you get a
callback maybe a second or third
callback and then I forget which one it
is and you eventually go to testing and
testings where you're doing your
audition again in front of like a bunch
of all the producers and the writers
thought everyone involved right and
there are people who I met who have been
flat-out told not just an assumption
but told their social media following
isn't big enough now when they apply for
certain roles or Toyota they asked how
many Twitter followers you have like
this it's kind of crazy how much this
factors in now more than just are you
talented or not there's always obstacles
that actors have to overcome but I think
especially here you know yeah well I
feel like there's it's weird to be like
how many people can you be directly
responsible for coming to see this thing
we're gonna involve you in or else see
you know and yeah it does break my heart
to hear that about people because yeah
it is it is like the most brazen way of
saying it's just about a number you know
and that could often be the deciding
factor between who gets a role and who
doesn't and it's it's it's fascinating
to watch the the walls come down you
know between us and you know celebrities
you and all the things in between it's
funny to think that this phenomenon of
social media overall is something that
affects everybody in similar and very
different ways because centering this
around acting and around you know the
industry so to speak it's funny because
there are things that are unique to that
like this situation with people not
being cast or whatever you know because
of their followings but also it makes
the barriers just between our lives and
the context we see all very different
and it definitely changes the perception
of celebrity on the other side of the
scale because now people have always
taken ownership of celebrities and have
formed emotional bonds to them but I
feel like that is accelerated in a sense
now absolutely I mean there's there
seems to be less of a separation of an
artist now like there's so many artists
seem to just they have to go on social
media they have to post and they have to
interact with their fans in some ways
that's a great thing in some ways that's
a really really cool thing and you know
it's like it's easy to just focus on the
darker side of these things where
someone [ __ ] up with a tweet or
someone messes up with an Instagram post
you know and it gets all this backlash
or whatever
but it's it's kind of weird and even
like with the YouTube you know when you
see like Will Smith has a YouTube
channel now freakin Jack Black has a
YouTube channel now this way of famous
people artists actors whatever musicians
to directly interact with their their
fans and directly influence them as it's
gonna sound incredibly hypocritical
because I feel like for myself if I was
an actor or had a different profession
right now outside of YouTube which is
all about directly interacting with the
subscribers and such I think I would
want to distance myself and limit myself
a little bit more from that I mean it's
cool if you're someone who's totally
fine with I remember Bo Burnham was one
of the first people to talk about that
actually at an event we I think we were
both there for I can't remember we were
both there if I was just there but Bo
Burnham was saying how he made an
intentional choice so like I'm not gonna
do if I like when vine was still popular
like I'm not gonna do vine anymore this
you this manipulation tactic that you
guys our friends with me is not true
talking about that there should be a
separation so that way you could just
take my work as what it is and not be so
invested who bo burnham the person is
and more of just what my work is that
I'm doing and that's always stuck with
me like I don't know exactly what he
said word for word this wasn't even a
recorded event at least it wasn't
something that went on YouTube or
something but the idea of what he was
talking about really stuck with me and I
feel like he stuck to his guns on it you
know yeah I don't really see him on
social media yeah periodically I'll see
him post some day on Instagram but it
seems like he really only posts when he
really has something that all of his
fans ought to know about or occasionally
when it's truly my new show to promote
yeah yeah exactly and that's a funny
thing too because now social media in
and of itself is not just one thing and
I think it's not this is kind of outside
the celebrity debate but I feel like
it's fascinating in a way because there
are no established rules of what it's
for with the prop
etiquette is with the proper protocol
like what kind of thing are we supposed
to be reading on twitter facebook
Instagram etc and so it creates a funny
landscape to me because it does create a
sort of tumblr filled with all these
different flavors you know and it's it's
weird
I gotta imagine to have that when you're
in a position like you know somebody in
the industry is especially if you're
visible yeah I also think that I've seen
a lot of people who were I'm not gonna
specifically name people only because I
happen to know a couple but there are
people that were working actors who had
TV shows or did movies and in order for
them to stay relevant cuz you don't
really see them on TV anymore and you
don't really see them in movies but in
order for them to stay relevant and in
the public sphere they have to
constantly engage with their personal
life on social media when their main
association was actor on a show our
actress and now they have to use social
media in order to seem like they're
still around you know yeah and that's
weird to me cuz that's gotta feel that's
gotta feel strange if you're cultivating
your relevance through this one channel
and and if you're especially just
stressed about that I have to imagine
that's a vacuum for your self-esteem in
a way has you gotta yeah then force
yourself to broadcast me it's always
funny to me when people say like I hate
vlogging but I'm doing it yeah cuz I'm
like that is literal you're just
recording your life and if you hate
recording your life yeah that is kind of
a weird contorted thing to do yeah and
it can be disingenuous then you know in
the connection with you and your people
well the flip side of it is the pursuit
of fame - which I find very fast I was I
was on a the John Campea show with
Robert Marr Burnett and after John
Campea logged us off Robert Marr Burnett
and I we were still you know able to see
each other and talk we talked about 25
more minutes and one thing we brought up
was how we they give him from you know
for us we were around before facebook or
myspace or YouTube was even a thing
so we never it grew III find it so
laughable whenever I meet a social media
an influencer or a YouTube personality
who's like [ __ ] cocky as [ __ ] like
they're actually kind of rare honestly I
don't really meet a lot of those kind of
people but once in a while you do and
that I find it funny when when you are
that person because most of us didn't
have YouTube or social media when we
were younger so this wasn't a thing we
strive for as kids like I didn't grow up
thinking I want to pee on the Internet
you know like that was another thing of
mine to be on the TV or on the movies
yeah this was like the ultimate dreams
in YouTube Arabia seemed like the middle
part for where I can like alright well
how can I make a living at least talking
about the things I want to do the basics
I'm talking about as a like my
girlfriend she works at a at a school
right now and she's constantly tell me
about and I and actually the guy helping
me find my new apartment the real estate
guy he was saying how his kid constantly
talks about how he wants to go to be a
youtuber and my girlfriend has works
with children who want to grow up to be
youtubers it's just so weird to me to
think like this is a thing that people
that kids now are wanting to grow up to
do so I think social media has not just
affected the industry of the people who
already exist that we see who made it
through acting or whatever now it's
affecting the kids in their pursuit of
things and I feel like even the pursuit
of Fame has its own narcissistic
qualities of course but I think now more
than ever that narcissism is gonna just
feel like people grow I want to be a
vlogger I want to do these things you
know I want to just use my personal life
to gain Fame I don't think it's all
negative I don't think it's all dark or
whatever I do find it very interesting
though how
fascinating super what a Grove to use
their personal life well yeah because
the thing is like especially with social
media the lines between life and
entertainment start to blur and the
duration and format of entertainment
starts to change and now we had people
making money making livings off of six
second loop video later it's fascinating
to watch everything change and then
wonder what is truly kind of the same as
it's always been and what isn't and I
think there is also an aspect to when
people die because I wonder before it's
like you would find out about that in
the news or in the papers something like
that you know it wasn't just this
instantaneous thing that we can then all
bandy around which is an interesting
thing that has changed now when
celebrity or a well-known figure dies
that becomes its own cultural moment
that feels just like it casts a much
broader net then perhaps it used to
unless it was somebody at the very top
you know yeah and the other thing too
that's occurred to me is that social
media I think has changed the industry
not just for the perspective of actors
both struggling and at the top in their
own ways but also because it's
essentially free market testing if you
go to Twitter YouTube I was thinking
about this the other day last night in
fact we were you were cutting the men in
black second trailer and I rewatched the
first video we did and and I'm not
trying to be arrogant so much as to say
that ah Sony watched but I started to
wonder because we broke down that
trailer and I was like you know kind of
every nitpick we had for this got
addressed in that second trailer and
which just led me to believe that they
have to because like reaction videos are
so popular because everyone's tweeting
because hashtags exists it must be so
easy for the studios to go and see what
people are saying
expecting hoping for and in the culture
where people especially you look at say
Warner Brothers kind of getting
trigger-happy on correcting things
meticulously I think social media feeds
that heavily yeah oh definitely I feel
like most of the main studios have
contacted us at least one time from
seeing one of our trailer reactions
and getting a little bit more insight
into how a lot of that works it's easy
to you can like go to a hashtag on
Twitter and try to determine what people
are saying but you can go to people who
have a following on YouTube and then see
what the comments are saying if they if
like if if we like a trailer and then
there's a lot of up votes for liking it
that tells them something if we don't
like something and there's not just us
like there we know there are channels
who are way more popular than us they're
watching Tyrone yeah beyond the trip
right so if they don't like something
and there's a lot of up boats and a lot
of comments and engaging of like I agree
this looks like [ __ ] that says another
thing you know look at the genie how
quickly we got another look at that
people they do pay attention to that it
is the free market it's the it's the
easiest way to get feedback as well
which I feel like can be at times a it's
it's easier to read into that as opposed
to when you know there were times where
I when I was much younger you know what
the hell are those called goddamn where
they called in so long since like focus
groups yeah you know there's no need for
focus groups a lot of the time now I
never get approached for them I don't
get a random email I don't hear of
anyone participating in there I'm sure
they still exist but there seem to be a
lot fewer because now you can just get
it through just like opinion based you
know anything you don't need real people
to jump into and drive rather than
getting probably 15 people in a room to
see what they think of it you know just
just see what the Internet's saying
about it cuz then you got hundreds of
thousands of people all chiming in of
what they think about this thing mm-hmm
you know it's it's pretty it's
fascinating to me I think it's I don't
think social me like my personal
relationship with social media is is a
whole other topic as opposed to the
business side of social media I didn't
even start really utilizing my social
media until I real because I I just
wanted to do YouTube and then once
YouTube this is you know algorithm and
pay way so it kept changing then I had
to start bill
social media up a little bit more and
even though I can get into the darkness
of it I get in the foggy mind of being
like I've been on my app too much I do
think there's a lot of great benefits to
it because there are some people who who
do get famous who want that interaction
with their fans and who are very natural
like you're gonna see people like Chris
Pratt you're never gonna see it Daniel
day-lewis they want that separation
maybe they want to only be looked up for
their work whereas you know to me it's
not all that far off from when famous
actors and actresses or musicians were
very personality driven as opposed to
just their art yeah and I feel like if
you're someone who just wants to be only
for your art you're not really gonna see
them on social media but someone who
like we want to see Will Smith be Will
Smith we want a secret sprat be Chris
Pratt they're gonna be social media
based and that's fine that's literally
no judgment against them that's just a
different kind of because there is an
art to it
depending on how you use it yeah weirdly
I think a lot of the thing I think is
super fascinating about this whole talk
is that it's created social media a lot
of new values to discuss and they all
have pros and cons like none of them are
just inherently good or bad really it's
felt like before we talked over it might
be like oh we don't make it but I'm like
no that's actually not a he's not a
hundred percent it's kind of 50/50 for
me yeah it's changed the way our world
works in a fascinating way and I think
you can kind of look at it through the
lens of like in certain ways it thins
out the barriers between the people
upstairs and the rest of us sure and it
gives a certain amount of power to just
the people contributing to the flow of
ideas on this machine so for better you
know people can speak out and cause real
change and for worse people can speak
out with bad information and cause some
nasty errors you know oh I also think
too because I'm trying to keep it in the
topic because of the Eric's question was
specifically about Fame and an industry
my favorite artist is Eminem and I feel
like something happened around
his rila I was a relapse not relapse nah
no not there was no the one before
kamikaze oh no no Reid oh my god all
stricken it was that caught John I have
been very sleep-deprived for the past
like six days really yeah well anyway
what were you going to say about it okay
no I revive revive the r-word yeah I
feel like around revival Eminem's just
discovered social media ya know it's
fuel in righteous indignation but like
what he did with the interviews post
that and YouTube being in another form
of social media you choose kind of weird
ground because it's not exactly
interacting even though they're trying
to form it more into it with their
stories a nerdy post now you've always
been able to reply to comments but now
they have more ways or they're trying to
make it more of a like a real social
media platform and what Eminem did with
Kamikaze we're just like bucket drop
that [ __ ] no heads up mm-hm it's kind of
a crazy-ass thing to me of how we have
this huge album with no no promo yeah
you know and that's the power of social
media because you get to talk you get
big it's shared so I think there's a lot
of really cool [ __ ] that can come from
you know yeah yeah and and in various
entertainment industries especially film
and music obviously I feel like there's
also just a lot more potential to get
your stuff out there and social media is
a huge part of that because you know
SoundCloud has blown up people get
plucked out of YouTube to make major
motion pictures now and you know that's
also a big thing is you can get your
work out there so much easier and the
drawback is you have to fight against a
current of other creators now who have
the access to but yeah I think the
catapult
is now designed differently because look
at like David F Sandberg got big from
some shorts he made and granted he had
the skill they were good shorts but you
know that got huge on YouTube and pretty
soon lights-out was a movie yeah as a
full movie it's a gray area there's
always gonna be pros and cons to every
part of the industry and with everything
pretty much but yeah I don't know what
are your guys's take on how social media
has affected Fame and industry and
whatnot leave it in the comments below
social media you guys can subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification Bill and Eric horseman
thanks so much for requesting this dude
I hope you do come out here in August
and we will buy you a drink and we will
snap photos without real rejects tattoo
you got in case you guys haven't heard
he has a real rejects tattoo and it's
big first guy only we're never gonna get
one because this channel gets shut down
one day thank you
[Music]